yeah when we talk about safe we're
talking about psychological that's right
yeah um uh and you can be
psychologically safe and still trip over
a court that's right yeah
um
uh
so it's it's a great story it's um i i
had a business trip to um las vegas a
bunch of years ago and the the client
was very generous and put me up at the
four seasons
um which is a lovely hotel and the
reason it's lovely is not because of the
fancy beds any hotel can buy a fancy bed
it's because of the people who work
there that when you roam the halls um
and somebody says hello
you get the distinct feeling
that they wanted to say hello not that
they were told to say hello um you know
we're highly attuned social animals we
can tell the difference i mean it's your
idea of being the nordstroms it's like
people can tell the difference whether
they're forced to give good service or
they want to give good service
anyway they happened to have a coffee
bar
at the four seasons in las vegas and
uh one afternoon i went and bought
myself a cup of coffee
and the barista working that day was a
kid named noah
noah was funny
and engaging and charming and i stood
there for far too long just to buy a cup
of coffee
and so
as is my nature i asked noah do you like
your job
and without skipping a beat noah said i
love my job
now in my line of work that's
significant because like is rational
right i like the people i like the
challenge i get paid well i like my job
love is emotional it's a higher order
connection like do you love your wife i
like her a lot right
it's it's different right
it's not the same
right
so noah said i love my job so
immediately my ears perk up this kid has
an emotional connection to his job so i
followed up and i said can you tell me
specifically what the four seasons is
doing
that you would say to me you love your
job
and without skipping a beat noah said
throughout the day
managers will walk past me
and
ask me if there's anything that i need
to do my job better anything they could
do for me not just my manager
any manager
and then he said i also work at caesar's
palace
and there the managers walk around and
just catch us when we're doing things
wrong
there they're just trying to drive
performance he says there i just keep my
head below the radar i just want to get
through the day and collect my paycheck
and then he said something magical he
said only at the four seasons do i feel
i can be myself
so think about that for a second this is
the exact same human being
right in two different jobs and yet our
experience of him
will be profoundly different
not because of him but because of the
leadership environment in which he works
in one experience it'll be amazing and
one it'll be terrible right
and i think so often i hear this all the
time leaders ask you know how do i get
the most out of my people well people
aren't a towel you don't ring them out
right how do i get the most out of them
it's a flawed question when it comes to
leadership the question is is how do i
create an environment in which my people
can work at their natural best and the
four seasons has figured that out
right it's by giving him
agency it's by giving him control to to
do the job that he wants to do the way
he wants to do it and checking in to
make sure that leadership isn't there to
do his job for him or to overly control
but to offer guidelines but also offer
support and the same goes in any
profession you can take a cop in one
agency who will be
high performing a valuable member of the
team a valuable member of the community
because of the culture you can change
the agency they work for
and they can
be
a terrible member of the team because
the leadership environment in which they
work